speaking of lovebirds you know if you're
out there and you're dreaming of getting
married in italy maybe you too hey
you're in luck there's good news insider
reports a region called lazio which
includes rome is offering couples around
the world they're offering them money
two thousand two hundred and thirty
dollars to get married there and yeah
and the campaign is called from lazio
with love and their goal is to revive
the local economy um and couples can
apply online all you have to do is spend
the money that they give you there in
the town locally on flowers dresses
venues catering photographers um and i'm
just you know i feel like i've done my
part for italy because i've been to
olive garden so many times you know
and you're welcome but um i don't know
getting paid twenty two hundred dollars
to get married there it's kind of cute
incentive right i'm so into this yeah
right
uh-huh they're ponying up like
i mean
okay real talk they're putting in like
10 million dollars into the commerce of
their city and
the thriving livelihood apparently like
um
17 000 couples about approximately used
to get married there annually and now
it's only like nine thousand because
you know business is down so they're
trying to revitalize by doing this and
this initiative i just feel like this is
so romantic and i have so many friends
that are getting married i know and i'm
i'm not getting paid for it i'll tell
you that much this sounds pretty good as
i'm planning right now and what you know
what i respect if a town doesn't have
like an industry uh that's bringing in
revenue create it yeah and so now
they're telling people let's become the
wedding capital of italy come here find
out why we're amazing good for you
logics very smart
story
well done
[Applause]
everybody get your love on and go to
lozio this is not the trailer they want
for their car they're fine with it
they're like no
um
was that an italian by the way yeah
[Music]
you